استجاب وزير العدل العراقي خالد شواني
لمنشده مساجين صوروه ونشروا فيديو لهم من
داخل السجن التاجي في بغداد
حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل فيك
[موسيقى]
قدامي امليله تاخذ غدا
الفيديو اللي شفتوه تم تسريبه من داخل
السجن ومثل ما سمعته انه زلاء بيتكلموا عن
تعامل اداره السجن معهم وقالوا انه بيتم
اجبارهم على تعاطي المخدرات وانه بينبالهم
موبايلات بمليون ونصف دينار عراقي يعني
1025 همم الفيديو عمل ضجه كبيره وعلى طبعا
هذا عمل دجله كبيره على من الصوت بشكل
وزير العدل خالد جوالي قرر اعفاء مدير
السجن التاجي ومسؤول شؤون الداخليه
واحالهم جميعا للتحقيق وعلى فكره هذه اول
مره بيطلع فيها كلام عن انتهاك لحقوق
السجناء في هذا السجن بالذات من سنوات في
كلام متقارير واخر المناشدات كان في
ديسمبر وان قال وقتها انه في سحب اعترافات
تحت التعذيب وقبور الرشاوه كمان